about nine years maybe 10 years ago nine
years ago I came across this children's
book that was called the man who walked
between the towers and was like like
eight or 12 pages of illustrations of
this and I I when I was in 1974 I wasn't
aware of this I you know I was in film
school so I must have been disconnected
from the world I didn't know that that
had happened but um and I and I and I
checked out this story and I found out
that it was real and the more I found
out about it I couldn't believe how
amazing the story was and I just you
know at that moment thought it could it
had the all the elements that you know
are needed to make a you know compelling
emotional and spectacular movie so I
contacted Philippe and he came out to
California and I had a nice long dinner
with him and convinced him to let me buy
the book and his life story and and
start developing the movie and your
films you I've always thought they put
the motion in motion pictures they sort
of hurdle us forward this movie of
course looks up but it also has a sense
of serenity to it a sense of calm that
works narrative Lee as well as with the
3d correct you know the thing that the
thing is is that this was sort of what
philippe did on the wire was sort of a
ballet and you know that lends itself to
working really good i mean you know when
you're doing an imax movie or 3d movie
you know it's it's important that the
camera kind of just sits there and you
know watches but the audience won't look
at the screen so that yeah it worked out
great Kevin they're about a million of
special effects that we could talk about
in this film I'd like to kind of get it
narrowed down to two or three if we
could small details one is that the
details of the towers themselves because
they weren't perfect you guys made sure
that they were sort of not cg perfect
they're sort of little flaws in them
that are kind of inescapable but still
there that you want to make it real the
other thing is that the bottom 30 floors
and the top 30 floors have details
inside the
windows and steve was mentioned to me
earlier that even if you look down when
he's on the wire there are fans moving
on the on the rooftops correct yeah now
the team went to town with thousands a
piece of reference photos all kinds of
foot any piece of footage that we could
possibly get and the funny thing is that
we kind of forget is that digital
photography didn't exist really at large
when the towers existed right so we had
to go off of old grainy film photos and
so the artist had to put a lot of time
and effort into figuring out exactly how
much detail how much motion in the city
how much imperfection and half of that
came from those reference photos and the
other half came from hovering a
helicopter above New York we got to go
right above ground zero for about two
days right in the exact spot that
Philippe walked so we could figure out
how much life and needed to be in the
city credible there's so many elements
to sort of keep track of and yet they
all meld together perfectly one of the
elements of Robert Zemeckis films since
romancing the stone in 1984 has been
Alan Silvestri Ellen the score for this
film is extraordinary it combines so
many notes it's got a playfulness to it
there's sort of a whimsical carnival
echo to it it's a caper film so there's
it's got caper elements to it and then
there's an ethereal grace really when
he's up on the wire as those notes all
sort of merged together for you what was
sort of one of the themes or lines that
was kind of going through it for you I
think the line ultimately was that all
of those themes had to be represented
Philippe as much as he wanted to get to
the other side was in his heart a
performer and so he wanted to get there
with a sense of style but he also had
all the understandable fears and and all
of the trepidation so I remember
approaching the walk which which Bob had
warned me early on would be very
challenging and it was and I remember
being kind to myself and only looking
from the moment his foot left the
building to his first arrival and that
was about a
Plus minute sequence and I thought well
this is exhausting it turns out it's
just the beginning so so you know I
think all of these themes had to be
there it was a ballet as bob says but
then in the next moment it's a
meditation and in the next moment it's a
body street performance and you had to
follow Philippe's trajectory emotionally
and physically with the music as Bob did
cinematically and you just had to submit
and go Steve from a producer's front of
use must be a wire walk in and of itself
there are so many elements to to keep
track of as it was moving forward what
scared you the most well really
recreating the walk I mean that was in a
sense it was the hardest but in a sense
came together quite well because Joseph
gordon-levitt committed time to work
with Philippe Petit and trained
extremely well not only really learning
a lot about Philippe in his heart and
his artistic process and who he was but
also learned his technique and then was
able to perform quite well on the wire
and bring that to life as a real actor
and that was really the key to I think
bringing the walk to life is getting the
heart and soul of the person walking
just not the technical aspect of putting
one foot in front of the other work for
about eight or nine days or so up at
Philippe's upstate home is that ride
from yeah we've walked him in wouldn't
hardly let him eat it just was he said
when you leave here you're going to
learn how to walk but it wasn't just the
walk he was learned he was training him
as a almost to do a ballet or he was
training him as a Philippe inspired
artists and so Joe came came out with
that kind of understanding Bob so many
so much of the film I think we're
obviously inside Philippe's head I just
want to contrast it for a second with
castaway where you have Tom Hanks alone
on an island and you would think well
here's a perfect chance for voice-over
and in fact you went the opposite
you know it was just us with Tom and a
lot of silence for an hour so that film
this film you would think well he's
going to be silent on the on the wire
when he's between the towers but we need
to be inside of his head to be able to
hear all of the challenges and
everything that he's calculating correct
right i mean the difference between that
and cast away is we you know everyone in
the everyone in the audience and cast
away immediately could put themselves in
Toms situation and they would be asked
him cells what would I do what would I
do what would I do and that's all tom
went and and tama and that in that movie
had only one eye one thought which is
how to survive what was when when i sat
down with Philippe and I sat down with
him and talk to him about this for hours
and hours and hours and and and Philippe
was a is an amazing storyteller and when
he would talk I mean I couldn't believe
you know when he was on that wire in his
in it he had this whole thing this whole
choreography planned out um and and you
know I put that Beethoven piece in the
movie too because he would tell me what
music was playing in his head when he
was doing his performance and I just you
know decided we had to just do that one
piece because that's what he said he was
thinking of when he did it but anyway um
he would tell me how he was feeling and
I thought you know that has to be in the
movie so I had to come up with a device
to you know make that part of the part
of the fabric of the movie so that when
he's on the wire we we could know what
was going through his head because
otherwise I think it would just be it
would it would be a you know an
important dimension missing if you were
just watching him you know walk back and
forth and perform back and forth without
knowing what he was feeling